canada is one of the countries that
really didn't accept many jews
before the war i'm wondering how does
that make you feel
like it made you feel that you're really
nobody
you know because we were we were
stateless jews
and uh america did not had a very bad
quarter system
i mean this was worse and and canada was
probably worse
and there were many people who didn't
want all these uh
stateless jews you know and so there was
no place to go and we had to get out in
a hurry
because my father had this summons from
the gestapo
to meet with them on the 21st of may
1939
okay we got out on the 19th of may 1939
and only because someone had told my
father you could go to shanghai it's an
open port
and if you could get yourself over there
somehow
you might be safe getting out probably
saved your life
yeah absolutely if we had stayed in in
germany
my mother never wanted to leave anyhow
because of her parents
but they left because of my sister and
me they wanted to save
us and that's how we got out if i
if we hadn't gone to shanghai i wouldn't
be here
that was an open port and about almost
20
000 jewish people from germany and
austria and also some from
poland um managed to make it out
to get over there and that's a chapter
of holocaust history that's not very
well known
it's become better known now because
people
are writing books and the movies out and
so forth
documentary films it was terrible
we um we came home from school my sister
and i my mother said we have to go
straight home
and uh it was brewing oh yeah
they knew what was happening but they
tried to shelter us
they wanted us to have a good childhood
and they didn't want
us to know that there were all these bad
things happening that people were being
taken away and
never heard from again and and people
were being knocked down on the street
and she said whatever you see on the
street
keep going just look down don't even
don't even stop and i thought to myself
i was what
eight years old then i thought if i
could just become invisible that would
be even better
but crystal night itself
my father fortunately had come home from
work
and he had a very good job at the
stationary firm
and we sat on the floor in our apartment
in the dark
and we were told not to make a sound she
didn't want the neighbors to know that
we were home
and we could have the screaming and the
yelling outside
and and uh people looking for jews and
yelling saying you know kill the jews
and all that
and that made an impression you know
i can't even imagine no and then
we we we stayed home for a day or so
after that
and then we went out and we saw all the
our synagogue wasn't
in all ashes you know they had burned it
down
and there was so much glass on the
street
and they they had jewish people come out
with their toothbrushes i'm not making
this up and had them kneel on the street
and scrub the street while people
were around there jeering at them
fortunately when we got to
shanghai there were there was help by
refugee organizations
american organizations and and the art
people you know and and
also some local russian jews helped
and then came world war ii and it was
all over again
then the japanese were in charge then
the japanese they were right there
all the time and then they took over and
if you had been an american
or a british or a dutch citizen they
would have put you in a detention camp
and that was very bad
it wasn't like a concentration camp but
it was close
they didn't kill you in there but there
was no food not enough food and
hygiene you weren't allowed to leave at
that point right oh no no no no
where would we go we had no papers
we had we were stuck there and then they
they looked around the japanese looked
around and
saw all these uh refugees german
refugees
jewish refugees and they didn't know
what to do with us
because we're kind of in a gray zone
there you know
and so the german government sent the
colonel mizinger over
he was at that point i think he was in
japan
and and he said to the
to the japanese commanders get rid of
the jews you don't need them
put them in the on ships and send the
ships out to sea
and drown them or
he brought with him and this is true i'm
not making it up
he brought with him a cyclone b gas
container
and said we're using this in europe and
it works and you could use that you only
have about 20 000 jews here
but the japanese for reasons of their
own
did not want to go that far and instead
of that they
put us with in into what they call the
segregated area
there was a ghetto okay you ended up in
a ghetto
yeah in china in china in in hong kong
and
in the other other side of the garden
bridge
the zoom call was amazing so there's
these two women who look
unbelievable at 90 91 right
and where all the families are watching
in the background
we were all muted and off screen it was
just the two women
and they start jabbering at each other
in german
and we're getting translations in the
chat room
spanish for those in south america
english for those in north america
and they're just getting right back into
it and
they go for about 45 minutes at least
at least and then the organizers of the
zoom
bring on all of our family
to say hi to the family in south america
and then we come off and they bring all
the south america families to say hi
to us and there are babies there's three
or four generations
on each side and everybody is
having bubbly and
all drinking it's it's a big celebration
it's a big celebration yes i can't even
imagine
and that is really really neat and her
family felt the same way
yes oh smiles lots and lots of smiles
uh he tears tears yeah except i didn't
cry and anna marie didn't she
no the two of them not you know but for
the rest of us
we were strong i'm just happy and we
were happy yeah they saw the romantic
part of it
but you just saw the practical my friend
is back and as soon as she started
talking
with me and i talked with her there was
a connection there
right away it's not like oh my goodness
who's this old lady over there you know
nothing like that
how did you find out what happened i
found out
from my director of education and
research
ursula chapinska and my deputy director
aaron blankenship
and they they had gotten a call from
one of our partners at the usc showa
foundation
and there was all this conversation
about you know betty tells her story
she talks about her friend anna maria
and there was all this story the
incredible
coincidence of someone at usc showa
foundation
happened to speak spanish happened
to be part of a memorial event a
commemoration event
for kristen act where
the original speaker was not available
this other woman came in took her place
and started telling a story and
so and to make those connections
again all sorts of weird things had to
happen i mean
it is it is it is extraordinary
um and that we were already everyone was
already partners
and um one of the exciting outcomes
of this is we are creating a partnership
now with the holocaust museum in chile
as well
so it's really been something that not
only
lifted up these two women um and lifted
us all up
personally but it's going to lift up all
of our institutions
as well were you part of the call the
zoom call no
so i was not part of the first zoom call
um there was staff on it from our museum
but uh not me
um i was part of the birthday party call
that we did a later call because i think
it's important
i did see the call and i read the
transcription
and to watch these
women reconnect
on screen is it was so emotional
it was just incredibly emotional
uh not only for the people that were on
the call but for those of us who were
watching
what was it that made it emotional it's
i is it
friendship partly or is it what they
went through i'm wondering was it
so so as we're talking i'm tearing up
remembering it there is
so i think it's that friendship that
connection that's so important and so
we of course look at this story through
the lens of the holocaust
but the truth is so much larger than
that
to watch two women
who had a connection at an early time in
their life
find that reconnection it just reminds
us all of how
important and how enduring
friendship is in all of our lives
that it was these two women who went
through so much
who lived this story during the
holocaust
that made it sweeter perhaps
more bittersweet